[Applaudissements]
fabrice guy bardon déjà ça avait
commencé sévère au ski je crois il ya un
truc très très jaloux qui s'était fait
traîner la scène des bronzés quand le
mari arrivent avec les affaires mais les
jalons tel joyau ma chance je trouvais
plus épais là je suis assez rassuré
parce que je trouve plus mais il est
très sympathique je le respecte
énormément
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on a une femme aussi merveilleuse que
carly un moment aussi il faut essayer
d'en faire partager les autres et je
crois que ton temps est venu à lévis les
palabres est venu boris peut-elle de
donner sa chance avec une personne à
part on n'a pas la même notion de
l'amoureux merci maintenant non voilà
dos les jambes demandé à ce que l'on
pense oui
le fan de bade du poison
des fois c'est vraiment
c'est des fonds dans cette audition non
mais c'est bien de remettre les choses
voilà voilà
et bien non on me dit ça pourquoi parce
que j'ai présenté le bachelor ça m'est
arrivé une fois d'exploiter le bachelor
est d'ailleurs attention le bachelor
parce que ouais c'est sa voiture de
résister sur le bachelor d'engagement
système verdonck et console est arrivé
en or mais attends j'ai quand même
laissé partir ma femme seule au bout du
monde avec des mecs après avoir hésité à
poil et je les ai vues elles n'avaient
pas tous y faire revenir foot c'est ça
et jean-michel ce croque force que vous
devriez vous excuser au maillet de boris
oui je commande remise à jean michel je
dois été le guen sait pas plus jean
michel est ce que je dois m'excuser mais
non c'est pas
la malade
[Applaudissements]
d'abord quand elle reste 9 avril à tony
côté là dedans il est très sympa très
beau couple
ils ont eu deux enfants et franchement
et maisons de regarder c'est vrai rôle
et s'embrassent alors merci d'avoir
accepté d'unir est bonne saint valentin
[Applaudissements]
merci d'avoir été là super